good morning heck it's Tuesday if
there's one thing I've learned from 104
year old Elizabeth Sullivan it's that if
you want to have a long and happy life
drink Dr Pepper this stuff is good it's
got sugar in it and three two doctors
have told me that if I drink it I will
die but they died first so today I'm
going to be blind test tasting Dr Pepper
diet Dr Pepper and three meaningless
knockoffs hold on actually you know what
I have to go vote
and I have voted and implore you to do
the same all right let's taste a real
one and some fake ones
oh you know what it tastes like it
tastes kind of like if uh Dr Pepper
where John coltrane's above Supreme this
would be uh I can also blow into a
saxophone all right on to number two
oh
hmm
that is Diet Dr Pepper it's not sweet I
guess there's like a tiny chance it's
the Whole Foods diet Dr Pepper like the
Zevia Dr Pepper but I I'm almost
positive that's die Dr Pepper so I'm
gonna try the third one now
oh boy
um
holy crap that's bad wow that makes the
first one taste like a Love Supreme wow
Jesus Christ
that's worse than water it tastes way
too Cherry the thing you have to
understand about Dr Pepper is that Dr
Pepper was invented by Charles alderton
who was a chemist this is essential to
understanding what makes Dr Pepper
interesting it was the product of a
chemist and the chemist wasn't trying to
make a soda that tasted like lemon lime
or like citrus he was trying to make a
soda that tasted like the soda fountain
at the Waco Pharmacy smelled he wanted
it in its Essence to be artificial this
tastes like it is going for a taste
which is all wrong like you don't want
to go for cherry or go for Cola or go
for sassafras roots and have a root beer
you want to go for the way the human
heart wants a soda to taste by the way
if that's Dr Pepper I retire I retire
from public life I walk away I do
something else with the rest of of my
life let's go to number four
oh I feel even more confident now
it's so bad Jesus Christ
I'm
I mean I guess it could be Mr Pibb and
go back to taste number one
no
no
I'm like 80 90 sure that's Dr Pepper
the complexity it reminds me of
Whitman's Leaves of Grass do I
contradict myself very well then I
contradict myself I contain multitudes
that contains multitudes hold on I want
to compare what I think is Diet Dr
Pepper make sure that I'm right
oh yeah I mean that's got to be it right
those are like the same chord played at
a different octave you know part of what
makes diet Dr Pepper so magical like for
a long time there are catchphrase ones
it tastes more like regular Dr Pepper
which it really does because like if I'm
right hold on let me you know what
before I start talking a big game I
should taste the fifth one
it's not bad I just feel like I've been
so confident and somewhat Cavalier and
now I'm starting to second-guess myself
like I'm I think
I think
that is Diet Dr Pepper
that is very sugary
and it has some layers but it's not Dr
Pepper I don't think it has a similar
problem to the first one which is that
there's plenty of sugar there's plenty
of sweetness but there isn't that
multitudinousness now I'm getting
nervous I know what diet Dr Pepper and
Dr Pepper tastes like okay John one more
time
that is Diet Dr Pepper please God be
diet Dr Pepper I'm gonna be in so much
trouble if you're not
yes yes okay then this is 100 Dr Pepper
yes oh thank goodness the remaining
three it doesn't actually matter to me
that much because they're not Dr Pepper
that's that's the important thing
um I'm gonna guess that the really
really bad one is the Whole Foods Dr
Pepper it almost tastes like cough syrup
to be honest with you
yes
so I I think this is the um Kroger one
Dr k
bikai is
it's better and in my experience anyway
store brand knockoffs are actually
better than like Coke or Pepsi knockoffs
Dr K oh
Mr Pibb they call it spicy Cherry Soda
well I'll tell you one thing that it's
not
spicy now I know what you're wondering
Hank John how are you going to turn this
into a sock commercial don't you worry
your pretty little face so doctors Evie
is like ugly socks that get holes
quickly that also have like
uncomfortable seams then we have like
cool-ish socks that just get holes in
them really fast so they don't turn out
to be that cheap because you can't wear
them that many times then for me the Mr
pip of socks is like fancy socks like uh
these socks are supposed to be for
working out and they have all these
bells and whistles but the thing is I
prefer to work out in my awesome sock
socks because they're just more
comfortable then we come to the Dr
Pepper of socks the awesome socks these
socks are perfect and 100 of the
proceeds go to charity that actually is
a distinct difference between our
company and Dr Pepper I know you're
wondering but John what is the diet Dr
Pepper of socks well I'll tell you our
new ankle socks which I don't have with
me because we just started making them
so whether you like ankle socks or
regular socks awesome socks dot Club
Link in the doobly-doo Hank I will see
you on Friday